so this phone is BlackBerry's iphone
killer and basically it's you missed
yeah it's it's it's wide right so here's
my question yeah sure what why does
blackberry feel the need to make an
iphone killer I mean their blackberry
iPhones you making a blackberry killer I
don't not consider the iphone to be any
kind of competition for the hardcore
business user it's a really nice piece
of hardware this trip is our comes down
really well the it's a nice shape it's
not too big although it's a little
bigger I think it's all you look I civil
you I've has a little heavy too yeah it
was a little bit heavy it's got some
nice camera action on the back three
times gotta pixel that's right it's
actually take some pretty sharp sharp
thanks but you know what the problem is
mmm well suppose know everything about
this phone very smooth have you met a
blackberry user can we like the phone
any blackberry user yes they don't move
slowly they are like the super fast sell
sell sell right Obama in the White House
you know that's what I think of when I
think of the you think of Barack Obama
well I had a blaster he does have a
blackberry you don't have this one cuz
that's too slow too slow for him this
phone is exclusively through verizon and
it's just for people who are on verizon
maybe have a contract verizon we have a
blackberry who maybe want to get an
iphone like device are stuck with a
verizon contracting i give this guy six
balls six out of ten balls if you don't
mind the slowness and you're a hardcore
blackberry nut you know and you want a
touch screen then you might want to
check this out if not get the blackberry
bold
there's a lot of stuff that comes out of
China this is the the high phone from a
company that shall remain nameless right
it's it's called the high phone I think
because you you'd have to be high to
actually buy it well here's a here's
something that's very interesting so I
was I was playing with this and it while
it actually looks like an iPhone on the
outside at first glance right it has a
screen right like that looks just like
the elephants like when you actually
bring stuff up on it like I noticed this
right here it's horribly horribly jagged
you see the thing is just beyond fake
like you know its advertising like that
that there's email but this is actually
your text messages in the email icon and
really all right so so how did you how
do you actually get this because I can't
go into an ATT store and buy one of
these right now I had to order it off
this janky website that was selling
these iphone knockoffs I had several
died why not give up that one so it's
not um act find calm yeah so it's
basically a website it has all these
like yeah I just on it just these kind
of shady products had to get some
customer service to figure out how to
use some parts of this thing oh like
what I just emailed this this lady just
some lady who called herself Mary
replied right it's obviously using this
google translator it costs a hundred
twenty dollars and the worst part out is
to ship it from China solid it's
something like 40 bucks to ship from
china so then you're almost paying the
same as you would for an iphone which is
you could get these for 200 bucks and
this is 160 they don't even the
differences you know this is on the lock
would you recommend this fall for
anybody I gave it a two out of 10 a two
out of 10 so we basically you avoid this
at all costs